hey I was gonna browse - beautiful today
we're playing another horror game it's
been a while this one is cold the rides
with strangers and I oh boy is that the
guy we're gonna ride with and right
so today's Valentine's Day and I better
just make this video and before Marzia
kills me so let's go you are
Alaura you have a very important job
interview but our car broke down so we
much hitch a ride to get there
oh god it's hot in here or is it that
the priest man have you seen her
can't [ __ ] see her how about that god
it's dark
ah that's embarrassing stand under the
arrow what era oh there it is there's
the car
goddamn I got it you got a hit to ride
zoom in the car and then place there at
it he sees me it hit this what do you
mean hate the space no you're not going
anywhere siya I need it ah he didn't
stop for [ __ ] what an [ __ ] you know I
would never run over anyone except that
one whatever okay look at the car look
for a car come on come on what do you
mean fan [ __ ] it [ __ ] you say ha
that was it that's all I gotta do show
him my tits is that what I did
Hey Baby how you doing Oh God is the
priest Hey oh good evening Oh God what
are you doing out there red flag here
take a seat and let me give you a ride
can't say no to a smile like that so I'm
gonna get in here yes thank you
I report in job interview tomorrow oh
boy thank you so much oh it's a little
bit awkward maybe I'll put on the radio
oh it's busted hey there are you doing
the sir oh god he's so bold I better not
looking I said what in here I'm gonna
turn on the
we needed to get away okay
Jesus
god damn he just yelled at you just
yelled at me whoo
I didn't know he was gonna do jump
scared the [ __ ] out of me son huh can we
stop it I think we had a squirrel I want
to go home now
well we have quite a ways ahead of us
may I ask where is it you are traveling
to come don't yell in my face please
so basically this game is like a hey hey
I heard that mate this is like a fresh
take on the finance of Freddy's formula
oh my god you hey you hit another
squirrel oh god breathe just breathe
just breathe
they're gonna be fine I am Mickey Mouse
apparently hey what's that knocking is
anything else gonna happen in this car
right I mean I get that as the concept
but it's a little boring just like five
nights of Friday's is the worst thing
are you sure my tits oh hey do creepy
son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] you god damn that's
creepy can't you just cover up please oh
hey hey hey no no no
oh good now got him [ __ ] all right
nice nice drive here's my stop okay
every guy said the priest again oh boy
it's the priest again he's my favorite
oh boy
okay let's do this it's not a moose fire
money you know if you have luck we 28 if
you fighting tonight oh ah ah come on
don't know
what is your problem I looked at you
deaf [ __ ] yeah you know I don't like you
how about that is it well we have quite
a ways ahead of us may I ask where is it
you are travelling to how can he say we
have a lot to travel if it doesn't even
know where we're going
you dumb poop of a [ __ ] god damn you
piss me off
bald son of him he's actually pretty hot
I probably let him touch me
when Navis a young boy my father hey how
you doing this guy calling me a slide
I'm trying very hard to complete this
level right now
I [ __ ] looked at him what do you want
from me
okay so I'm reading through to make sure
I understand and I was right about the
gameplay is that if I answer the
questions right he's less likely to
attack me or yell in my [ __ ] face oh
boy
okay let's do this no how about you look
somewhere else besides my tits [ __ ] can
we put on some Bianchi please oh oh God
we're not even halfway there this is
literally me in the car oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
that I didn't I mean I can imagine
sitting someone with a car who goes like
this like I'd want to kill that person
as well
no stop creeping up oh god it was fake
tuck and roll tuck and roll baby
[ __ ] this [ __ ] oh god we got to find
another car now hey stop the car at once
please are you talking to [ __ ] hey
I'm walking here
haha this is my strategy right now god
yeah hey
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] you
kidding me
are you kidding me what was that [ __ ]
[ __ ] up duck in the [ __ ] okay so that
was rights with strangers I like that
it's a take on the finance of Frederick
ready for moolah but it has the same
problem like you saw me I got scared the
first time because I didn't know what to
expect and then after that it just kind
of went downhill like it wasn't as scary
anymore so you know the game is still in
development I hope that they keep that
in mind to to kind of keep things fresh
and interesting and I think it can be a
fun game so that's it for now let me
know what you think as well thank you so
much for watching this video leave a
like if you enjoyed and as always